كان لديه برنامج تلفزيوني ناجح
كانت في 60 من العمر وكانت تبلغ من العمر 27 عامًا عندما
التقيا في بطولة للجولف في عام 2006
حيث تقول ستورمي دانيلز إن دونالد ترامب
شارك صورًا لزوجته طفله الجديد
ومارس الجنس معه نعم
وترامب  أنكرت ذلك منذ ذلك الحين ولكي
تثير هذا النوع من الحماقات وأن
تثير مطاردة الساحرات طوال الوقت ،
فهذا كل ما تريد التحدث عنه ولدت
في لويزيانا ، دخلت ستيفاني كليفورد في مجال
الترفيه للبالغين في سن المراهقة وهي تحمل
الاسم العنيف من حسابها  لقد
اعتقدت أن ترامب قد يساعدها في الوصول إلى التلفزيون
بدلاً من ذلك ،
احتلت مزاعمها بعلاقة غرامية عناوين الصحف ، وهو ادعاء رئيسي مع
وصول حملة ترامب لعام 2016 إلى البرقيات التي
تقول إنها تلقت 130 ألف
دولار للتكتم عنه
ونفى أي علم بذلك في
ربيع 2018.
اشترت في نفس الصيف هل كنت تعلم
عن المدفوعات أه لاحقًا علمت أن
قصتها بدت مربكة في بعض الأحيان
على سبيل المثال في وقت من الأوقات وقعت على
بيانات تنكر حدوث أي علاقة غرامية
إذا كانت غير صحيحة
لماذا وقعت عليها بسبب  لقد جعلوا الأمر
يبدو وكأنه ليس لدي أي خيار ، أعني أنه لم يكن هناك أحد
يضع مسدسًا في رأسك وليس
عنفًا جسديًا ، لا تعتقد أنه
سيكون هناك نوع من
التداعيات القانونية إذا لم توقع عليه بشكل
صحيح في واقع الأمر
الجملة المستخدمة هي أنها يمكن أن تجعل
حياتك جحيماً بعدة طرق مختلفة
تزيد من تعقيد الأسئلة الآن في قلب
القضية القانونية المرفوعة ضد ترامب ، هل أتى
المردود المزعوم من أموال الحملة
وكان ذلك انتهاكًا
لقوانين تمويل الحملة الانتخابية محامي ترامب السابق مايكل
كوهين الذي ذهب  إلى السجن بسبب أموال
الصمت المزعومة يقول نعم وأن
ترامب كان على علم بذلك لكن آخرين في
فلك ترامب يقولون إنه لا توجد طريقة أن المال
لم يكن أموالًا لحملة آسف لأن
الرئيس السابق قبل أيام فقط
وجه دانيلز إلى دانيلز
وأصر عليه مرة أخرى.  لم تفعل شيئًا خاطئًا
في قضية وجه الحصان لم تكن لها
علاقة مع Witch Hunt